Thierry Mendon le secrétaire d'État la
réforme de l'État et à la simplification
et l'invité de Preuves par 3 bonsoir et
merci d'être avec nous pour ce
rendez-vous avec l'AFP et Karine Perret
nous rejoindra sur Public Sénat avec
Perrine Arnaud qui vous interrogera sur
votre idée de loi CDD c'est à dire à
durée déterminée et Karine elle
reviendra avec vous sur vos propos mais
c'était ici même ils avaient mis le feu
mi-novembre vous jugiez qu'une primaire
serait indispensable y compris pour
François Hollande François Hollande
justement que l'on dit déjà engagé dans
sa pré campagne pour 2017 Thierry Mondon
certains à droite lui reprochent une
double faute morale ces jours-ci ne pas
avoir été en Russie pour les 70 ans de
la victoire sur les nazis et on sait le
prix payé par par les Russes et avoir
rencontré fidèle Castro le dictateur
qu'il dénonçait dans une tribune au
Nouvel Obs en 2003 est-ce que vous avez
été heurté ou est-ce que vous êtes
réticent au moins dans un des deux cas
je viens d'évoquer mais qui sont
critiqués
non
en Russie enfin Moscou la France était
représentée par le ministre des Affaires
étrangères donc au plus haut niveau
compte tenu du déplacement du président
et donc il y a pas de mauvaise manière
vis-à-vis des Russes bien au contraire
on peut même interpréter la présence le
8 mai de du de du ministre des Affaires
étrangères comme la volonté de la France
de garder un lien avec avec les Russes
quel que soit les difficultés qui nous
opposent aujourd'hui quant à la
rencontre avec finale costereau moi je
trouve que c'est bien que la France
laisse pas la place aux Américains seuls
à Cuba et je pense que les Cubains ont
besoin de relation avec l'Europe et ils
ont choisi la France comme point d'appui
de libéralisation c'est pas Fidel Castro
aussi
la tenue protocolaire dans laquelle
Fidel Castro a reçu le président montre
que que voilà il y a des moments au-delà
de même de la politique il y a des
rapports d'hommes qui sont utiles
d'entretenir
il y a la charge contre Bercy de
l'ancien patron des DF Henri Proglio qui
renonce à la présidence du groupe de
défense du groupe électronique Thalès le
gouvernement a-t-il cherché à l'abattre
comme il le prétend pour des
considérations politiciennes non je
crois que ce monsieur que je ne connais
pas ne manque pas de toupet
ce qui lui arrive et l'aboutissement
inéluctable de l'aveuglement déontologie
dont il fait preuve voilà quelqu'un qui
souhaitait présider un des premiers
groupes de défense français Thalès qui
par ailleurs est conseillé d'une des
grands acteurs du nucléaire civil et
militaires russes et qui voient pas le
conflit d'intérêt possible entre ces
deux responsabilités franchement le
ministre Emmanuel Macron a très bien
fait de tenir bon et il a d'autant plus
raison que on voit bien on peut compter
parfois sur les grands patrons pour
s'auto réguler pour eux-mêmes avoir un
code de déontologie qu'il s'applique à
eux-mêmes manifestement il y a des
exceptions et il est bon que dans ces
moments-là la puissance publique un peu
rappelle type de réalité donc il a bien
fait deux renoncer puisque c'était sa
décision oui il a passé pas un geste qui
fait spontanément au contraire mais
c'est grâce à Emmanuel Macron qui a bien
fait de rappeler des principes de tenir
bon sur les principes et on peut être un
peu choqué de l'attitude de
caca mille longtemps à regarder la
réalité il manque pas de poupée alors
vous rajouter aux critiques parce que
lui il dit j'en ai marre on me fait
passer pour un trade pour un Gouin pour
un espion pour un guignol il est tout ça
tout ça est un peu contradictoire mais
la réalité c'est que la déontologie
minimale et un peu de lucidité oblige à
considérer quand on veut être patron
d'aller principaux groupes de défense
français on n'est pas conseillé de
principal groupe de nucléaires civils et
militaires russes et ces deux positions
authentiquement incompatibles la
bataille politique ferrages plus que
jamais autour de la réforme du collège
et des programmes également à combien de
temps Najat Vallaud-Belkacem va-t-elle
pouvoir tenir alors que on le voit
François Hollande et Manuel Valls tous
les jours se relaient pour la soutenir
ils ont raison de dire c'est une bonne
réforme d'ailleurs moi je suis persuadé
que ces interrogations tout à fait
normal c'est pas une petite réforme à la
réforme du collège d'abord elle est
indispensable et c'est vraiment une des
grandes réformes du quinquennat qu'il y
ait des débats autour de cette réforme
c'est normal mais que on mélange un peu
tout et que la plupart de ceux qui
critiquent n'est pas pris la peine de
lire le texte
adressé au pseudo intellectuel moi je
respecte le débat d'opinion qui soit
donc j'ai pas de problème par rapport
aux intellectuels qu'est-ce quel que
soit leur propos et même quand je suis
en désaccord avec eux en revanche je
crois que beaucoup des critiques qui
sont faites aujourd'hui à ce texte sont
l'objet de gens qui ne connaissent pas
le texte ou qu'il dénature et la
ministre va dans les semaines avec la du
gouvernement remettre les points sur les
i je pense que cette réforme non
seulement sera voté mais que Najat ne va
au québecassem sera le ministre de
l'éducation nationale bien longtemps
que répondez-vous à Nicolas Sarkozy
alors il a lancé lui une charge très
virulente contre la ministre d'éducation
nationale jugeant je le site qu'elle
parvient à dép Christiane Taubira dans
la course effrénée pour la médiocrité
que répondez-vous que Nicolas Sarkozy
s'attaque toujours aux personnes c'est
quand même tout à fait étrange qu'il est
pris en grippe hier Christiane Taubira
aujourd'hui Najat Vallaud-Belkacem et en
même temps ça se comprend au regard du
bilan qu'il a lui-même a valoriser de ce
qu'il a fait quand il était président de
la République en matière d'éducation
nationale on comprend qu'il préfère
parler d'autre chose c'est pas une bonne
manière de faire et plus généralement
puisque il est fan de Victor Hugo j'ai
envie de de lui rappeler que Victor Hugo
lui-même disait que la rancune est une
dépense introductive c'est pas bien et
c'est pas utile de se positionner en
fonction de ce qu'on aurait voulu
demeurer être et pas en fonction de la
réalité des faits d'ailleurs il y a pas
de critique de fond sur sur la réforme
et tout simplement parce que je crois
que les principaux points de critique
sont des points qui ne tiennent pas
l'examen précis du texte pour vous le
moteur d'une Nicolas Sarkozy ça ne
serait que la que la rancune l'esprit de
vengeance je le crois je crois que ces
propos personnels ces attaques
personnelles indécentes contre les
ministres hier Christiane Taubira
en effet le fruit de cette rancune alors
il n'y a pas que les les femmes en
l'espèce qu'il critiquent il y a aussi
quand même la réforme sur le fond tiré
Mondon il la juge désastreuse et même
peut-être irréversible pour notre
République il n'est pas le seul à le
dire vous avez cité les intellectuels
des grands noms comme Alain Finkielkraut
par exemple qui dénoncent également une
réforme désastreuse et une fureur
antiélitiste
et il a regardé les programmes
l'approche globale de l'enseignement
que la question de savoir si notre école
doit promouvoir un modèle d'excellence
pour tous qui nécessairement génère une
élite et ça c'est
le grand combat qui a toujours mené la
gauche
absolument pas bien au contraire nous
disons simplement que c'est pas des
collèges que ça doit se passer qu'au
contraire quand on est collégien
c'est-à-dire quand on a 10 ou 11 ans il
est trop tôt pour être déjà parquet dans
les très bons élèves ou ceux qui
vraiment devront faire avec le moyen
d'anti dispose que l'enjeu du collège
c'est la démocratisation de
l'enseignement le plus longtemps
possible l'élévation du niveau de la
qualité de l'excellence pour que les
plus brillants ensuite au lycée et leur
chance et donc nous voulons faire
désigner l'élite les élèves méritants
qui sont peut-être pour certains issus
de bonne famille entre guillemets
dirigée contre personne et diriger pour
je prends l'exemple d'un des points de
critique qui est fait par un certain
nombre de personnes encore une fois faut
entendre les critiques qui est la
suppression des classes bilingues en
sixième 15% des collégiens les classes
bilingues en 6ème sont remplacés en 5ème
par 100% 100% de classe bilingue pour
tous les collégiens voilà est-ce que
dans un cas on détruit l'éducation
nationale en donnant la possibilité à
tous les enfants dans aujourd'hui il y a
des élèves extrêmement motivés qui
viennent de tous les milieux sociaux
un élément de diversité sociale
important au lieu ils attendront un an
et au lieu que ces classes soient
réservées à 15% des collégiens elles
seront ouvertes à 100% des collégiens
moi je crois que c'est un progrès ça
remet rien en cause ni l'excellence au
collège ni même la capacité des élites à
faire leur chemin c'est des opportunités
ouvertes à toutes les familles à tous
les enfants de France vous dites que
Najat velo Belkacem est là pour durer en
quelque sorte au ministère de
l'Éducation nationale pourtant on a
l'impression que la mobilisation je le
répète du président de la République de
son premier ministre jour après jour
montre en fait sa situation de faiblesse
non c'est pensais pas ça c'est que Najat
vallaud-bécacem d'abord la décision
qu'elle prend aujourd'hui sur une partie
de ce qui fait polémique c'est-à-dire
les classes bilingues le latin le grec
c'est une décision c'est un décret il y
a pas de débat parlementaire parce que
le débat a eu lieu c'était la loi payant
et donc il y a pas l'occasion
d'expliquer de débattre vraiment avec la
représentation nationale dans le détail
des objectifs qui sont les tiens puisque
les siens puisque le travail a déjà eu
lieu et probablement ce moment de
pédagogie parlementaire qui n'est pas
programmé manque et je crois beaucoup
des problématiques aujourd'hui si je
mets de côté la mauvaise foi ou là la
rancune tienne à ce déficit d'expliquer
de cassions il faut pas la laisser seule
c'est l'affaire du Président c'est
l'affaire du Premier ministre mais c'est
l'affaire tous les membres du
gouvernement de de d'expliquer ce qu'est
réellement et ses intentions encore une
fois l'excellence pour tous les parents
d'élèves ne seront pas convaincus par
vos arguments ni ceux de la ministre
est-ce que vous n'allez pas finalement
favoriser enseignement privé avec cette
réforme est-ce que certains parents ne
vont pas être tentés dans le vés leurs
enfants de l'école publique
ce serait quand même tout à fait curieux
qu'en créant des postes supplémentaires
4000 postes supplémentaires en
renforçant le soutien des élèves qui ont
des difficultés en offrant la
possibilité à tous les collégiens de
France d'apprendre deux langues des lacs
vous le savez en diluant certains
apprentissages par exemple dans des
approches pluridisciplinaires c'est
aussi critiqué par certains professeurs
grève d'ailleurs en même temps les
classements internationaux montrent et
les pays qui réussissent dans les
classements internationaux
l'interdisciplinarité c'est vraiment une
nécessité
pédagogique et si c'est cette réforme
est engagée par Najat vallaud-bac c'est
pas parce que le collège marche bien
c'est au contraire parce qu'il marche
pas bien du tout et qu'on sait que c'est
le maillon faible de l'enseignement en
France aujourd'hui c'est à ça qu'on
s'attaque et je suis convaincu que les
résultats seront assez rapides
reconnaissez qu'il faudra un effort de
pédagogie pour cette réforme peut-être
même des adaptations il faut de la
pédagogie et des adaptations il faut
peut-être des des aménagements et
notamment ça va être le cas sur les
programmes d'histoire une couleur là
pour le coup il y a une consultation qui
est engagée de vis-à-vis des parents et
vis-à-vis des enseignants donc il y aura
sûrement des modifications mais il faut
oui par définition il y a des
propositions d'une autorité indépendante
en l'occurrence Conseil national des
programmes a voté la loi Macron les
socialistes se sont abstenus pour la
plupart certains ont voté contre la
majorité a semble-t-il a pris Emmanuel
Macron au pied de la lettre en
libéralisant encore plus en simplifiant
davantage la majorité la majorité
sénatoriale c'est la majorité du Sénat
effectivement non alors la droite qui
n'est pas la majorité qui n'est pas la
vôtre souvenez-vous quand vous aviez la
majorité de gauche au Sénat et elle
n'était pas forcément derrière vous non
plus alors en tous les cas la droite
sénatorial a voté de la loi Macron
est-ce que vous lui faites grief d'avoir
encore une fois libéraliser un peu plus
et simplifier ce qui est votre votre
cœur de métier j'ai envie de dire moi je
le dis très calmement avec la majorité
sénatoriale qu'on a eu l'occasion déjà
de débattre très longuement quand j'ai
présenté une loi de simplification qui a
été adoptée en décembre ce désaccord
c'est en effet sur la simplification
pour la droite sénatoriale simplifiée
c'est enlever les droits
c'est à dire qu'en gros l'idée qu'il y a
derrière ce ce mécanisme c'est que c'est
la loi c'est la règle qui complique et
moyen de règles et Mions sport et
personnellement je pense exactement
l'inverse je pense que simplifier c'est
fait au nom du droit c'est-à-dire que
simplifier c'est pas enlever des droits
c'est rendre les droits plus accessibles
plus lisible donc plus efficace et ça
donne quoi ça donne une volonté
finalement mais en même temps ils sont
très partagés les sénateurs parce que
d'un côté ils font de l'affichage
politique il supprime la pénibilité il
supprime la loi Hamon sur l'information
des salariés en cas de rachat
d'entreprise de fait il crée un
dispositif les accords dit offensifs qui
permettront de contourner les 35 heures
bref c'était une idée
qui a Bercy
c'est de l'affichage libéral mais c'est
des convictions libérales avec
lesquelles je suis dans un désaccord et
en même temps sur bon nombre d'articles
du texte reconnaissant qu'ils ont fait
un travail parlementaire remarquable et
qu'il y a des articles qui sont tout à
fait bonifiés par leur passage au Sénat
alors qu'à une période d'AFP arrive on
va voir avant cela avec Audrey Greta
c'est que révèle ça va vous plaire
Thierry mendons la dernière livraison de
l'enquête fracture française dipsos
fracture qui se réduisent en fait
notamment sur la question du libéralisme
côté socialiste
le libéralisme fait son chemin dans
l'esprit des sympathisants socialistes
pour relancer la croissance par exemple
une enquête ipso c'est sopra Steria
montre que 34% des sympathisants PS sont
des estime qu'il faut donner plus de
liberté aux entreprises au détriment de
l'État il n'était que 23% en 2014 c'est
une évolution qui est assez
significative pour le coup et qui montre
que finalement d'une certaine façon les
sympathisants socialistes suivent la
ligne économique du gouvernement et elle
montre aussi que les frondeurs et
notamment ils ont été très actifs très
actifs au moment de la sur la loi Macron
n'ont pas réussi à convaincre les
sympathisants socialistes une défaite
idéologique des frondeurs Laurent Baumel
n'est pas de cet avis par une petite
acrobatie il explique qu'il y a surtout
un problème avec la définition du terme
sympathisant socialiste je crois
qu'aujourd'hui lorsqu'on demande à des
gens de se qualifier ceux qui se disent
soci aujourd'hui dans les enquêtes
d'opinion sont souvent des gens qui
adhèrent à la politique gouvernementale
actuelle Laurent Baumel se concentre sur
la forme Christophe caresse chef de fil
du pôle des réformateurs comprend
surtout que les sympathisants
socialistes soutiennent le changement
face à la crise la gauche aurait tort de
s'enfermer dans une
conception purement j'allais dire
protectrice ou défensive elle doit être
capable d'accompagner aussi ce sentiment
des Français qui veulent réussir qui
veulent s'épanouir dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui ce que je reproche
fondamentalement quand même un certain
nombre de mes camarades c'est d'être
dans une posture
qui est une posture d'empêchement
de blocage un tacle de Christophe
caresse plutôt mal perçu dans le camp
des frondeurs mais moi je conteste
l'idée que le mouvement c'est le
libéralisme on peut faire des réformes
de gauche on peut faire des réformes
sociales démocrates je respecte les
hommes mais je suis farouchement hostile
à ce qu'il représente idéologiquement
parce que je pense que c'est
potentiellement destructeur de l'idée
socialiste les deux écoles ne s'en
cachent pas leur opposition a été
exacerbée par la présence de la gauche
au pouvoir reste maintenant à connaître
le penchant des militants ce sera le 21
mai prochain lors du vote des
différentes notions
de l'Agence Française est avec nous
bonsoir Karine vos questions à Monsieur
Mandon oui alors on verra ce qui se
passera effectivement au Congrès du
Parti socialiste début juin mais là
est-ce que vous diriez comme le prétend
ce
cette étude qui a d'ores et déjà une
défaite idéologique des frondeurs avec
une adhésion de plus en plus forte des
sympathisants pour libéralisme je crois
qu'il y a une nouvelle identité
socialiste qui n'est pas encore formulée
suffisamment précisément peut-être elle
le sera-t-elle au Congrès peut-être le
certain après
qui finalement nous permet de sortir de
cette espèce de jeu de rôle qu'on vient
de voir c'est pas le choix aujourd'hui
entre aider les entreprises et arrêter
de redistribuer ou redistribuer au
détriment de les entreprises à
l'évidence on voit bien qu'on a un
nouveau mode productif à trouver qui est
fait de plus grande prise en compte de
la réalité économique et la réalité
économique c'est que nos entreprises
françaises les petites comme les grosses
elles ont un être soutenu parce que dans
la croissance internationale aujourd'hui
elles font pas le poids par rapport à
bon nombre de leurs compétiteurs en tout
cas une bonne partie du tissu industriel
donc politique de l'offre tous les
nouveaux cours de la politique
de François mais c'est pas fait
seulement pour faire plaisir aux
entreprises c'est fait pour les salariés
des entreprises et pour ceux qui
aimeraient bien le devenir et donc en
fait c'est authentiquement un projet qui
est articule l'économique le soutien aux
entreprises et le social l'emploi est à
terme on l'espère le pouvoir d'achat
donc faut pas opposer il y a pas de
vision ceux qui aiment les entreprises
et ceux qui aiment le social parce que
de toute façon quand il y a pas de
richesse à distribuer on peut pas
distribuer donc il y a possibilité de
formuler
cette nouvelle idéologie sociale
identité qui a fait d'une articulation
repensée entre l'économie et le social
on reste dans les sondages une étude de
l'institut d'Axa disait récemment que
70% des Français préfèreraient Manuel
Valls comme candidat en 2017 à François
Hollande est-ce que vous faites partie
de ces 70 %
de Manuel Valls qui travaille au service
des orientations du président de la
République donc je souhaite que le
Président de la République réussisse
parce que voilà pour l'instant on n'a
pas les résultats qu'on souhaiterait
mais on désespère pas de les obtenir
assez rapidement et si jamais le temps
file je crois que c'est très important
votre question et c'est le mot de temps
que c'est il faut que les politiques de
gauche comme de droite comprennent que
la vitesse des sociétés
déconnecte la vie publique la vie
publique c'est beaucoup trop lent c'est
complètement désynchronisé par rapport à
la vitesse d'adaptation qui implique les
sociétés donc il y a plein de choses à
repenser dans la fabrication des lois
dans la fabrication des normes dans la
simplification dans la façon de faire la
politique on y reviendra on va le
changer non mais je crois pour être très
concret que l'année 2015 donc il reste
encore une neuf mois environ enfin un
peu moins c'est peu de l'année des
premiers résultats et ça c'est l'enjeu
pour le président de la République et
s'il réussit il y a pas de raison que
ils disent bah écoutez les gars
récemment et puis il s'est fixé trois
objectifs dont la confiance la confiance
entre la confiance des Français comment
peut-il alors que justement à la reprise
économique n'est pas là et le chômage
est toujours aussi fort écoutez c'est
probablement le point sur lequel on a
les plus gros progrès à faire la
question de la confiance mon sentiment
c'est que quand bien même nous aurions
des résultats économiques et je pense
qu'ils vont arriver et nous aurions les
résultats sociaux notamment en matière
de chômage je suis pas certain
que ça recrée de la confiance disons les
choses autrement je pense que la crise
de confiance la crise démocratique à une
autonomie en dehors de l'économie et du
social et que la question de la défiance
des Français à l'égard des politiques ce
qui gouverne comme ceux qui ont gouverné
on va parler de ceux qui gouvernent oui
elle est beaucoup plus profonde il y a
évidemment une dimension économique et
sociale mais il y a des dimensions
identitaire et une dimension de
finalement qu'est-ce qui fait la vie
donc ça veut dire ce que je suis en
train de vous dire ça veut dire qu'il
faut prendre aussi des initiatives sur
le plan du redressement démocratique du
pays
de transparence dans les motivations de
la décision publique je prends un
exemple le président de la République a
accepté une idée qu'on lui avait suggéré
il y a quelques mois de rendre public
les avis du Conseil d'État sur les
textes de loi parce que c'était les
secrets de la République et la
conséqualisée ça c'est légal ça c'est
pas légal désormais c'est public il y a
plein de domaines dans lesquels les
motivations de la décision publique les
les raisonne qui conduisent l'exécutif à
décider peuvent être rendus publics et
puis c'est l'ouverture des données
publiques je rentrais pas dans le détail
deuxièmement plus d'éthique monsieur
Nadal vient de faire un rapport où il
propose un renforcement des lois en
matière de de
fautes
et je pense que c'est propositions sont
pratiquement bonnes de deux raisons la
participation
je pense que on est dans un on vit
l'émergence d'une nouvelle forme de
démocratie dont on n'a pas tiré les
conclusions c'est très simple la
démocratie représenteative est contestée
n'est pas contester dans son principe
même elle est contestée dans ses
modalités d'exercice les parlementaires
peuvent pas tout faire les français
grâce au numérique ont accès à
énormément de connaissances suivre
beaucoup plus la vie publique et ils
veulent participer plus à des processus
décisionnels sur ces trois plans là
transparence éthiques participation à
redressement démocratique est possible
et ça ça recréera de la confiance mais
justement sur qui est la République
exemplaire que défendait le candidat
François Hollande on a vu par exemple
récemment trois proches de Manuel Valls
être nommé préfet hors cadre la chef de
cabinet de de François Hollande
également on parle d'un autre
consolation pour Jean-Paul Huchon à la
région puisqu'il s'est désisté de
l'investiture du Parti socialiste au
profit de Monsieur barthelin on a quand
même l'impression que tout ça ça relève
pas ce qu'on dit ce que vous dites là
c'est pas des photos ça relève des
pratiques politiques ce qui fait passer
République exemplaire pas tout à fait la
même chose les
manquements éthiques sont sanctionnés
par la loi comme ils ne l'ont jamais été
les ministres qui ont fait des erreurs
ont démissionné aujourd'hui même
monsieur
Balkany et son épouse sont traduits
devant je sais plus quel tribunal pour
tous les manquements pendant
l'évaluation donc
les règles ont été renforcées je pense
qu'elles peuvent être plus encore les
pratiques politiques ça particip e de se
redressement vous reconnaissez que
effectivement il faut faire attention
lors des nominations
sur la transparence sur l'éthique sur la
démocratie la participation qui
suffiront c'est aussi en effet des
nouvelles pratiques politiques et de ce
point de vue là je suis très confiant
par exemple de du développement de la
parité dans les dans les élections ou
cantonale maintenant vous avez autant
d'hommes que de femmes demain en
régional ce sera probablement la même
chose je pense que ces changements-là de
génération
oui pour l'instant
du 85
mouvements là c'est des nouvelles
générations qui apparaissent en
politique des nouvelles façons de
concevoir la chose publique qui qui
apparaissent et je pense que ça va
infuser obligatoirement sur la durée ce
sera long des pratiques politiques
nouvelles qui feront de la démocratie
française une démocratie mature ce
qu'elle n'est pas tout à fait encore
alors vous parlez de la participation
des électeurs ça nous amène tout droit à
la question sur les primaires oui vous
ici en novembre dernier vous nous disiez
que vous seriez favorable à ce qu'il y
ait une primaire en 2016 avec François
les écologistes les Radicaux de Gauche
enfin le maximum de parties de gauche
représentées pour être au deuxième tour
en 2017 vu les scores du Front national
est-ce que vous tenez toujours ce propos
c'est très difficile d'être à la hauteur
de la saison 1
pour avoir du succès donc je c'est pas
d'actualité comme comme
intellectuellement je peux penser ce que
je veux et je change pas facilement
d'avis mais ça n'est pas d'actualité
politique dans les statut du PS
je vous ai répondu c'est pas l'actualité
encore une fois intellectuellement
chacun libre de penser ce qu'il veut
propos vous embarrassent depuis le mois
de novembre
est-ce que vous obtiendrez gagner une
possibilité que vous obtenez gain de
cause est fait en tout cas en tout cas
ce qui est sûr c'est que dans une vie
politique durablement tripolaire
durablement tripolaire si on veut être
au deuxième tour il vaut mieux
rassembler au premier et donc les moyens
de rassembler au premier la façon de
rassembler au premier la volonté de
rassembler au premier tour sont une
condition indispensable d'un éventuel
justement en français Hollande est en
pré campagne et il pense à se
rassemblement il doit il va devoir pour
2017 certainement donner des gages aux
écologistes concrètement ce qu'il est en
train de comment est-ce que qu'il peut
faire pour que Cécile Duflot ne se
présente pas de son côté pour quel gage
peut-il donner aux écologistes le combat
pour l'écologie dont les Verts
ce process
des avocat les champions
il se fait au gouvernement aujourd'hui
avec la préparation des enjeux
climatiques dit cop21 fin d'année
le gouvernement notamment le président
Ségolène Royal et le ministre des
Affaires étrangères qui pilotent ce
dossier sont motivés comme jamais
d'ailleurs si le président voyage
beaucoup dans le monde aujourd'hui c'est
aussi pour présenter ce préparé ce défi
là s'il réussisse l'accord international
qui sera une grande première ils ont
fait pour le théologie plus que
n'importe quelle formation politique et
je ne vois pas comment sur quelle base
une formation politique
s'opposerait au bilan écologique d'un
gouvernement qui réussirait l'enjeu au
Cap 21
proposé de s'en occuper ils ont pas
voulu Manuel Valls a proposé à Madame
duflotz s'occuper de la cop21 d'être
mise de l'environnement elle n'a pas
voulu c'est voilà donc on va le faire
sans eux on va essayer de réussir
malheureusement pour les régionales ce
serait quand même
tout il en faut deux donc il est mieux
d'être soudé d'être assemblé surtout
quand franchement les différences
il faut être expert en politique pour
pour les lire très précisément vous nous
dit que la présence d'un candidat ou
d'une candidate écolo en 2017 et en fait
les conditionné au succès ou à
l'échecs
que nous on est tendu vers des enjeux
écologiques c'est une des premières
priorités des mois qui viennent pour le
gouvernement et je vois pas qui est
désaccord entre nous et les versions ces
sujets-là et si on arrive par avec leur
soutien sans leur participation à faire
triompher cet enjeu là on aura vraiment
rempli la case écologie et Environnement
du quinquennat et donc pas de
remaniement prévu d'ici
juin septembre pour un nouveau
gouvernement
des adaptations
et des ministres qui vont peut-être
partir en campagne qui vont être
souhaités sur la campagne je sais pas
j'ai pas de nom donné parce que je suis
pas encore les candidatures sont pas
officiellement prononcées enfin ça peut
arriver il y a la question de de la
recherche de l'enseignement supérieur
qui est un sujet en soi qui mérite
probablement quelqu'un qui s'en occupe
donc il y aura sûrement des aménagements
le président
calendrier avant l'été après l'été on ne
sait pas oui
on attend merci Karine Perrine terno
arrive maintenant pour évoquer votre
action et vos idées notamment des lois à
durée déterminée et LDD première
explications avec sama de chir
l'Assemblée nationale a adopté le Sénat
a donc adopté adopter adopter adopter
chaque année une centaine de lois est
adoptée en France pour lutter contre
l'inflation législative Thierry Mondon
propose de créer sur le modèle
anglo-saxon des lois a duré déterminée
le principe si un texte ne fait pas
l'objet d'une évaluation dans les trois
à cinq ans il est supprimé une
proposition qui ne suscite pas vraiment
l'enthousiasme des sénateurs je ne suis
pas pour cette idée de loi temporaire de
loi cliniques de loi jetables mais je
suis partisan que lorsque l'on fait une
loi on est dans la tête que cette loi
elle va durer ça peut être au contraire
un moyen de provoquer de l'inflation
législative parce que si vous devez
remettre l'ouvrage sur le métier
systématiquement tous les trois ans et
si les lois sont un peu comme dans les
messages de Mission Impossible et se
détruisent dès qu'on les a lu ou au bout
33 ans alors ce sera l'instabilité
législative d'une part et puis d'autre
part il faudra religiférer à chaque fois
Jean-Pierre Raffarin lui est favorable à
l'idée de loi a duré déterminée il avait
lui-même déjà formulé la proposition
mais reconnaît qu'elle est juridiquement
contestable à partir du moment où on
organise un droit ou on donne des
obligations le fait de les limiter dans
le temps peut posséder des graves
problèmes pour les personnes qui ont
accès à ses droits ou qui doivent
respecter ces obligations un argument
partagé par ce spécialiste du droit
Constitution personnel pour qui l'idée
est bonne mais difficile à mettre en
oeuvre il faut tenir compte de ce qui se
sera passé pendant la durée de vie de la
loi est-ce que véritablement on peut
supprimer une loi sans la remplacer par
quelque chose si elle n'est pas
systématique l'évaluation des lois
existent déjà en France elle est faite
par les différentes commissions
parlementaires mais il s'agit plutôt
d'améliorer les textes que de les
supprimer
cette proposition décapante et là vous
avez encore même dans votre musette
d'État d'idées comme ça décoiffante
aussi qui est l'ancien président de la
commission des lois au Sénat c'est ce
que vous voulez créer en France
je respecte trop la fonction
parlementaire et trop la fabrique de la
loi pour considérer qu'on peut voter des
textes et les jeter à la poubelle et je
voudrais commencer juste très brillant
par ce point là il est impératif si on
veut rétablir la confiance avec les
citoyens
d'améliorer grandement la qualité de la
loi et de la fabrique de la loi
oui mais il faut que ce soit une
meilleure qualité je prends un exemple
tout bête il y a des lois qu'on vote et
qu'on peut pas appliquer ou qu'on
applique pas
la plupart du temps pas seulement je
prends la question de la pénibilité
c'est nous qui l'avons fait voter je
suis pour le principe de la pénibilité à
l'heure où je vous parle elle s'éloigne
ne s'applique que partiellement parce
que on a des difficultés pour
l'appliquer complètement
ça veut dire que le Medef a raison
et donc là il y a plusieurs problèmes le
principal problème et j'arrive à ma
proposition le principal problème c'est
que c'est il est faux dans toutes les
démocraties européennes que j'ai été
étudié de près il est fou on est les
seuls pour lesquels la loi est magique
c'est à dire une fois qu'elle est votée
c'est génial ça c'est un principe qui
remonte à très loin ces plateaux qui
disaient que c'était la loi était la
décision politique du plus grand nombre
sans limitation dans le temps donc
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire qu'est-ce que
font les Anglais c'est la fameuse loi
Disson cette cause moi j'ai pas parlé de
loi des mots de durée déterminée ils
disent on veut une loi et on a un
rendez-vous législatif obligatoire deux
ou trois ans après faute de quoi la loi
s'éteint mais vous avez entendu les
arguments du
reporte finalement ça crée encore plus
d'instabilité législatives et ça accroît
l'inflation législative parce que s'il
faut refaire des lois au bout de trois
ans cinq ans vous avez prenant la
pénibilité cette loi s'applique et puis
dans trois ans on a un rendez-vous
législatif c'est-à-dire pas un rapport
parce qu'aujourd'hui on ce sont les
différentes commissions du Parlement
partout la cour des cons tout le monde
fait des rapports donc tout le monde se
fiche donc là rendez-vous
après il y a un débat parlementaire avec
une évaluation de l'application du texte
éventuellement des amendements qui
permettent de corriger tel ou tel effet
qu'on n'avait pas anticipé et donc la
loi continue et s'il n'y a pas ce
rendez-vous législatif la loi 16 c'est
ça et la proposition et je pense alors
prends pour discuter
avec une évaluation qui est des
conséquences législatives non pas qu'on
demande un rapport qu'on enterre et que
ce rapport fasse l'objet d'un débat
législatif
mais vous même dans votre vie
professionnelle vous passez votre temps
à prendre des positions à corriger à
améliorer à regarder ce qui se passe
sauf si vous êtes un esprit ce dont je
ne doute pas supérieur
es et légis
latifs forcément ce qu'une majorité fait
l'autre majorité c'est des tricots et
sera tenté peut-être justement d'effacer
ainsi de faire tomber des lois qui ont
été votées par les majorités précédentes
c'est pas pareil si on regarde là aussi
ce qui se passe à l'étranger il y a ça
produit deux choses ce mécanisme
premièrement ça oblige à se préoccuper
des questions de mise en oeuvre concrète
des textes sur votre
gouvernement là actuellement on s'occupe
pas déjà de la mise en oeuvre des textes
qui sont votés on s'en occupe
une partie de mon travail
qui est tombé à 59 je sais pas s'il a
baissé je pense qu'il est trop bas et je
pense moi aussi j'ai une autre
proposition là-dessus je pense qu'au
bout de 6 mois quand une loi est publiée
les décrets doivent sortir donnant six
mois administrations pour les sortir et
au bout de 6 mois tout doit être public
publication ou pas des décrets parce
qu'aujourd'hui personne ne sait quand
vont sortir les décrets si ça va sortir
si ça va sortir donc publicité de l'état
de la publication des décrets six mois
après le vote du noix ça aussi c'est une
mesure de transparence positive mais je
reviens juste sur la loi dit à durée
déterminée la loi donc ça a deux
conséquences premièrement on est obligé
de se préoccuper des effets concrets de
la loi convote et pas de manière
culturelle intellectuelle concrètement
puisqu'il y a un rendez-vous législatif
et deuxièmement comment c'est qu'il y a
ce rendez-vous législatif on prépare
beaucoup mieux la loi qu'on s'apprête à
beauté et on essaye en fait d'anticiper
les conditions mises en oeuvre ce que ça
créera réellement avant même que de
voter le texte de loi le jour on fait ça
on a des lois d'une bien meilleure
qualité on a donc une parole publique ce
que vote les députés ce que vote les
sénateurs ça va s'appliquer parce qu'on
a bien réfléchi avant même le vote de la
loi aux conséquences concrètes et aux
conditions d'application de ce texte
alors de remarque par rapport à ce que
vous venez de dire l'exécutif qui
dénonce donc un peu cette lenteur et
cette inflation législative François
Hollande qui disait lui-même et il y a
quelques semaines lors d'une émission
que six mois voire un an pour faire
voter une loi c'est trop long mais
est-ce que les exécutifs ne sont pas
avant tout responsable eux-mêmes de
cette inflation quand on voit
effectivement le nombre d'amendements
qui viennent du gouvernement trop texte
et puis le nombre d'amendements
trop de textes du coup l'action publique
est illisible
et du coup la machine administrative est
préoccupée sans arrêt les décrets qui
doivent sortir des ordonnances et elle
est concentrée là-dessus premièrement
trop de texte deuxièmement et il est
clair que on doit faire attention à
l'application
systématique des décisions est rapide
des décisions qu'on prend systématique
et rapide donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que une fois que la loi elle est
fabriquée donc encore une fois il y a
les six mois de de décret et ensuite les
choses doivent se mettre doivent se lève
mettre en oeuvre et donc des lois votées
plus précisément
ce sera des lois plus efficaces et donc
vous incitez également vos collègues du
gouvernement et même le Premier ministre
a freiner un petit peu leur vitesse
effrénées et leur quête est perdu de de
loi parce que il se passe pas une
semaine par exemple sans que le premier
ministre annonce une nouvelle loi et ça
lui permet aussi d'exister non
enfin c'est pas son propos mais là vous
avez raison il faut s'occuper du flux
législatif moins on demande de
simplifier les règles qui existent si
pendant que je simplifie et à chaque
jour ou chaque semaine une loi nouvelle
qui rajoute on ne va pas s'en sortir
donc le grand changement du prochain
programme de simplification que
j'annonce début juin ce sera un
dispositif plusieurs dispositifs de
régulation du flux législatif inspirer
des exemples danois des Pays-Bas de
l'Allemagne et de l'Angleterre qui
permettent de réguler vous verrez ça
dans quelques jours
il y a quelque chose qui en Allemagne
s'appelle contrôlera qui s'appelle en
Angleterre le RGP regretter et en
français ça va s'appeler ça va s'appeler
le comité d'impact entreprises c'est un
groupe indépendant d'entreprise qui
chaque fois qu'un texte a vocation
économique sera élaboré par l'exécutif
pourra si le gouvernement le souhaite
donner un avis en même temps que le
Conseil d'État donc ça rallonge attend
un avis indépendant sur les conditions
concrètes de mise en oeuvre du texte
dans les entreprises si on a eu ça la
suppression de la taxe professionnelle
il y a quelques années tous les effets
induits qu'elle a eu on aurait été
alerté par ce comité si on avait eu
seulement de la pénibilité on aurait été
alerté par ce que vous voulez des
lanceurs d'alerte
qu'avant de voter mais comment ils font
les Allemands les Allemands regardent
besoin est-ce qu'on a besoin d'installer
un comité
finances au Sénat alors pourquoi
l'Assemblée nationale
avec les ministres ce qu'on a besoin en
plus d'un comité pourquoi des textes qui
sont votés ne s'appliquent pas c'est
bien parce qu'on n'a pas pensé avant en
associant les parties prenantes ceux qui
sont chargés de mettre en avait tech on
les a pas associés au processus
législatif je vais vous donner l'exemple
du SMIC à l'entrepreneurs en vitesse je
peux pas être trop long il crée le SMIC
c'est pareil un changement considérable
c'est des enjeux ils ont cet instant cet
instant et saisie du texte elle y
attendait les gars ça va pas ce que vous
proposez ça va pas si vous pensez pas un
régime spécial pour l'école porteurs de
genou pour les cueilleurs de cerises
pour les jeunes pour les chômeurs de
longue durée votre SMIC un peu plus de
de 8 euros ça marchera pas donc le
gouvernement temps avant de voter la loi
cet avis indépendant on prend une partie
à son compte modifie ce qu'il avait
prévu de faire voter va au Parlement
bundenstyle et fait voter à 90% son
texte et ce texte s'applique
immédiatement le lendemain le SMIC en
Allemagne
de 0 à 8 euros un peu plus de 8 euros du
jour au lendemain donc de négociation
est compris dans le monde mais plus fort
c'est pas allemand en France ce même
dispositif existe en Angleterre il
existe au Pays-Bas il va exister en
Italie il existe donc ça s'appelle les
programmes
on a l'impression à vous écouter que les
parlementaires sont des nuls jamais vous
poser
lentilles parlementaire
qui connaissent les dossiers c'est ça
l'intelligence d'un parlementaire c'est
d'écouter les avis de la société civile
le parlementaire il est pas forcément
tout à fait dans la situation du
directeur des ressources humaines qui
doit appliquer tel texte sur la
formation professionnelle ou du
regretter juridique il doit appliquer
tel nouveau texte sur le droit de
l'urbanisme il s'agit pas c'est pas être
incompétent que d'écouter ce que les
gens avisés ont à vous dire sur ce que
vous apprêtez à faire c'est au contraire
être particulièrement intelligent mais
est-ce qu'on rajoute c'est comprendre
que la loi c'est sérieux on rajoute une
strate en termes de délai j'insiste là
dessus ça se fait en même temps que du
Conseil d'État exactement en même temps
21 jours circuit normal sept jours
régimes donc ça ne rajoute aucun délai
et en revanche ça éclaire la décision
des parlementaires qui restent et
décideurs après charge à eux de faire ce
qu'ils ont envie
après un filtre oui après un avis
indépendant
mais il y a la même chose pour les
collectivités
les collectivités il y a le Conseil
national des normes que vous avez
présenté au mois de juin pour l'instant
moi je mets l'instance
cet instant sa disposition du
gouvernement à partir du 1er juillet
sera rattachée au Conseil de
simplification elle serait prête à
fonctionner dès que le gouvernement
souhaitera la vie de cette commission il
pourra la saisir d'accord donc ça ça va
être présenté début juin pourquoi ne pas
pousser finalement la logique jusqu'au
bout et supprimer une des chambres
parlementaires supprimer le nombre de
parlementaires il y avait une réforme
institutionnelle
c'est pas forcément des choses
auxquelles il faudrait
de s'interdire de penser
je parle de réduire le nombre de
parlementaires
il faut pas que ce soit des mesures
prises comme ça pour pas avoir une
circonstance il faut que ce soit dans un
nouveau de contrat de confiance entre le
peuple et
le monde politique ces élites politiques
ce sont des pistes plutôt à l'occasion
je crois que vraiment la question du
redressement démocratique elle passe par
un nouveau contrat entre le peuple
français et ses représentants encore une
fois ça c'est plus la gauche pour la
droite on ne recréera la confiance que
si on crée ce moment de de volonté de
ressaisissement de démocratique et de
notre système politique une grande
réforme institutionnelle qui pourrait
être dans le programme d'un candidat à
la présidentielle par exemple
puisqu'on évoquait Claude Bartolone
est-ce qu'il peut rester président de
l'Assemblée nationale tout en faisant
campagne en Île-de-France les régionales
de décembre
de la campagne ce sera quand le plus tôt
possible selon vous il peut si vraiment
il a des situations qu'ils mettent en
difficulté il peut faire briser
l'assemblée par un vice-président c'est
pas une difficulté ça se fait dans très
nombreuses séances donc il peut rester
président de l'Assemblée
candidat contre une autre députée
candidate elle-même à la région qui va
pas démissionner de son mandat de député
d'avoir été avec nous aujourd'hui la
semaine prochaine Perrine Tarnaud notre
invité sera le Défenseur des droits
Jacques Toubon il est de plus en plus
sollicité on parle de plus en plus de
lui il viendra s'expliquer sur son
action et sur certaines de ces
interventions à très vite